good morning John I'm not going to say
I'm a bad writer I think I'm a pretty
good writer but I will say that I
generally write my best stuff when I'm
not doing what people consider writing
not that interested in metaphor or
lyricism or beautiful language at least
not for their own sakes I don't tend to
think about how words sound beyond
rhythm I'm mostly strive to say the most
with the least number of words and to
communicate complicated things as simply
as possible and usually that serves me
very well but sometimes there are just
things that can't be said that way which
often leaves me unable to communicate
effectively the things that I feel are
most important my dog died she got
cancer osteosarcoma which is very common
in greyhounds nobody knows why it almost
always metastasizes immediately to the
lungs and the only treatment is
amputation which is painful and
short-term many dog owners choose to
simply manage the pain which is what we
did and now I'm very sad I'm sad in a
weird way where I will forget why I'm
sad while still being sad and I will
think why am I so sad and then I will
remember and feel guilty for having
forgotten I'm sad in a way where
sometimes I won't even have thoughts I
will only have sadness and my mind will
interject and ask why am i crying and
there will be no reason just the crying
I don't pretend to have known the mind
of my dog I will never understand how
she thought of me or how she understood
her own life really all I can know of my
dog is the effect that she had on me and
that I suppose somewhat selfishly is
maybe the important thing lemon was a
dog and she was my dog and she was
special and valuable and amazing but
also not any of those things in every
way she was just another dog she wasn't
a treasure but she was my treasure we
all get so caught up and living in such
a big world with oversized people making
their mark and maybe we think that in
order to be valuable we have to be like
that even if the mark we may
is made of dirt ugly and easily wiped
away we should be making a mark as well
but look lemon was a dog just another
dog lots of people liked her but she was
just a dog but damn it if I didn't think
she was important damn it if she hasn't
left a hole in my heart nothing matters
but to each other and lemon mattered to
me people always asked me when meeting
lemon if she was a rescue
I was always kind of uncomfortable
saying yes even though I guess it's
technically true but it's not as if I
got her as an act of goodwill we adopted
lemon because we wanted a dog and
because greyhounds are good dogs
they're relaxed and loving and adorable
how could we consider this an act of
charity buying for a small fee a cuddle
companion and a reason to get out of bed
on Sunday mornings and somebody to blame
your farts on we didn't rescue lemon we
just got a dog but I didn't really get
what was in it for me
because as much as her life got better
after she was adopted after living life
not abused but more as livestock than a
pet my life must have gotten better than
hers because in valuing lemon noble and
ridiculous and just another dog I
learned that feeling valued and knowing
that you matter is much more about how
you think of others than about how
others think of you
and that's just one of the thousand
things that that dumb dog taught me and
and I guess is still teaching me thanks
lemon John I'll see you on Tuesday